a quiet Backstreet targeted by French
police in October last year
following a tip-off from British
intelligence the era had been under
surveillance for months officers knew
exactly where they were going to an
unassuming lock-up garage
when the door was wrenched open they
found this the tools of a
people-smuggling gang responsible for
sending hundreds of migrants across the
channel indings
persona
the raids led to the arrests of six men
Navid Safi peshwa Hassan and Abdu adame
Alan Muhammad Ali zamaresa and hafeed
belkool
four have been on remand ahead of the
trial in the way
but Safi and adame made their own way to
court
social media accounts showed the lives
the Smugglers had built in France this
is Hassan and adami together next to one
of the migrant camps where they touted
for customers
the court was shown life jackets similar
to those found in the garage was told
they'd colluded to expose migrants to
huge Danger
they were given prison sentences ranging
from two to five years verdicts
acclaimed as a Triumph of the
cooperation between Britain and France
it's been one of many uh significant
operational results over the last two to
three years so jointly with France we've
disrupted 59 organized gangs at the
Heart of Heart of this trade and we're
building on that collaboration seeking
to go further Upstream in tackling the
supply chain of the boats and the
engines
the French prosecutor insisted the gang
did or deserve to go to prison the
answer of the French judicial
authorities to human trafficking and
human smuggling is and will remain
absolutely merciless gel
and jail for many years it is a hard
line Echo by Rishi sunak who's made it a
priority to stop the flow of small boats
across the channel well the verdicts
handed down in this court are a triumph
over a people smuggling gang they're a
sort of vindication of that closer
working relationship between Britain and
France but the problem is that every
prediction suggests that more migrants
are trying to get across the channel in
these small boats so the two nations are
going to need a lot more days like this
one in court
the tendrils of smuggling run much
further we found this Smuggler's boat
near Dunkirk and traced a valve on it to
Turkey
in Istanbul a boat maker confirmed to
Sky News that he receives regular
requests to supply Smugglers with the
dinghies they need
[Music]
it
foreign
ERS are sent to prison new gangs with
new boats and new plans will simply take
their place Adam Parsons Sky News do way